Molossia is an expression of personal
sovereignty creativity imagination and
maybe a little bit of - of satire like
to poke a little bit of fun it's got
easy to do that we have a tiny country
inside a gigantic country I am President
Kevin Baugh there were President of the
Republic of Molossia this is my nation
welcome the Republic of Molossia right
over there is the United States and
right over here is our country my nation
is a micro nation which means a tiny
self-declared nation and usually located
within another country as is Molossia
inside the United States the United
States does not recognize Molossia
although we did get a very nice
Christmas card from President Obama I
would say that the u.s. considers a sort
of an extension of free speech for the
record we do pay taxes however we call
it foreign aid you've seen their roads
the US needs all the help they can get
so we're there for them we like to do
things that are different and unique and
unusual Molossia we are actually very
proud of our space program yes Malati
does have a currency it's called the
Valora
which means valuable in Esperanto which
is our second language that we also have
our measurement system our total
population right now is 32 and we have
our own time zone many of our civil
servants and Molossia are mannequins
because they don't complain and they
don't charge a whole lot never go on
strike that kind of thing
there are hundreds of micro nations
around the world in just about every
country you can imagine the conch
republic which is Key West Florida a
seal and a very famous micro nation
located off the coast of Britain it's
really an amazingly creative group of
people that decide they want to have
their own country I originally founded
the Republic of Molossia back in 1977
when I was 15 and I just stayed with it
through the years it is a lot of work
running Molossia because I want Molossia
to be a functioning nation I want it to
be as much like a larger nation as it
possibly can be I love being the
president of Malaysia I really do
the second only to my family is one of
my great loves in life
[Music]
the more passengers for climb up a
linguist go get it through introverts
landihilio-- go go go
anybody know anybody for fun note plans
clung llanfair sudden veils between
gifts go get it we little foursome
Cecilia Coco golf bright it's a small
town in northern Wales around 76% of the
population here speaks Welsh it's also
the longest town name in Europe with 58
letters there are literally four LS next
to each other right there what is with
this name Chandler put Quinn give coke
Eric we're in trouble Santa Silvio go go
go is not the original name of the
village he's got to be kidding
in the 1860s the name was contrived by
the local cobbler and it was meant to
bring in people and tourists Alan help
us break this name down
the name means places within the village
you've got this church Mary in the
hollow of the white hazel near to the
rapid whirlpools at the Church of
Cecilia and the red caves okay so let's
say you want to mail a letter do you
have to write the whole name postmaster
Jim Evans you could but your doctor
writes very small or you could use a
short version which is the first 20
letters if you play for the local
football league does the name fit on
your jersey team manager Steve Smith it
does and it's the longest name of any
football team in the world and it's just
about fits can you say it after a pint
pub owner Kevin Bryant I'm sure I can
let's see
clever pork we get ok if we drop this at
the city oh go go go
but can you put it in a song club for
fanfare poodle son let put gringa coke
addict friend of weeks and cecilia go
google it might be the greatest PR son
of the mid-1800s i don't know even of
today after all we're here here in
sanford put Quinn get go get it wind
Robo Santa silly oh go go go that's
pretty good in spring during Wisconsin
there is a house on a rock but it is so
much more than that inside it is home to
many bizarre and incredible collections
there's a room of self playing
instruments an infinity room a giant
squid attacking a whale and some
nightmare-inducing dolls it seems like a
really strange museum and that's because
no it appears to be Museum because it is
housing antiques it's housing all kinds
of memorabilia and things from a
different era it's more of a place to
just enjoy so what is house on the rock
the house on the rock to me is a magical
complex it's an all-around sensory
explosion it was made by Alex Jordan who
was an architect not at all not at all
he is not a trained man he's just a man
of great vision maybe not an architect
but an evident hoarder Alex Jordan with
the help of his friends built the house
on the rock in the 40s and opened it to
the public in the 60s his collections of
antiques and junk new items and old real
and quite obviously fake have
north central theme or apparent reason
for being that and maybe that's part of
its charm there are some pretty
incredible things including a huge
unraidable carousel 269 different
animals not one of them is a horse
really yes the horses are drawing the
walls of course they do you know every
time you turn the corner here it's a
different thing and it's a different Wow
and you don't know what to expect
one man's trash is another man's
roadside tourist attraction today's
journey takes us to the Dutch town of
guitar G Thorne is just like any normal
town with one exception roads they don't
have them the immense of the sine alpha
is open boat someone's going down
violently the feature of the platform a
semi-coma
and all this much local severe egg burns
by deaden a local burger minister from
Quito
now I design fear and rent a home that
Imams over here and I love homeless
Persians and boats lots of boats now who
adduction no fear zone for faithfulness
s all the board is available either heat
or that's young one of the town's
residents he's known for punters a flat
bottom boat that originated in detour
hey fellow Stanek he daughter Mara
Montiel
how to act over there over the elevator
and where there are boats there are
bridges 167 to be exact and just like
any town people leave their groceries
their furniture their beer you name it
but in G thorn they must pass through an
time he's the town's bridge guard also
plasters today stopper and lift at
little daughter Steel
when they look at that often three on
the boat well we're just the opening for
one of those boats is the fire boat this
is Bart and Eric I need to haul that
Black Dahlia there's a middle row need
Conoco those dude hidden door okie
toward ya feel plane
Phil warning about this world loosing
from John Connor all right Murdock for
the rather from the Knievel drinking and
boating the sinking design of and this
is young he's in charge of maintaining
the natural lands around II thought I
was alone kid or on the Mesa Ryland and
sang Horner better a boat brag bad and
yeah
the queen of the boat that's even a
don't need to fill me my Roberta's and
she'd wanna know how ferocious animal so
there you have it
the residents of Keith or improved their
life without asphalt traffic and trips
to the DMV can be pretty damn great
roads who needs him baggy torn
[Music]
nation a Singapore MIDI Amiata Jay
Wratten boto a diameter Greg McKeown
single bizarre cannot a kingdom quality
study room Watney
he made the controller would need bigger
another vasana Kadena Condon equipment
jack mccann sangolo interior bar woody
vamanos America shani shingnapur is a
village within maharashtra an indian
state with one of the highest crime
rates in the country but the community
of about 3,000 people in this village
worship a Hindu god Lord Shani and they
believe Shani will protect them from all
harm America Lilia hey the Maha panic
jaga - averted Marcia who disposal
system ie Jewish Kamala it additionally
charged say the past episodes or easily
deny here and now current seppuku Negara
which was a high he had about Sulu hoon
army Anika at name togarashi show arts
partners up Lily I'll open it everything
about saw you with me the stumbled upon
a cure system salute Hawaii should be
local or depends kirtana nikidik my
neighbor's Reba her Gowalla yellow the
Khalifa Tom Shizuka na
lucky for Allah Allah through the
luckily philosopher Russia or Enoshima
Merida and Chester they were I mean
Dada panda Panda reduce Larry Bihari no
Yamcha mamata shankar cheat me mg dude
sorry Wilma - jimana mother Crocker
cinema releases audacity to trigger one
on Khalid original Allah Christian
Amara's total crew correction when Adam
to completion Emirati Adam just read
dirty deeds apply mullah progeny deeply
as marine police report any don't put up
on t km calc and the hood parental
authority me solution
[Music]
you
[Music]